how do you think that the right fights
back against this because again it's not
just from government
uh it's it's in academia it's in the
corporations i mean i think that the
right thought for
decades that the corporate world was
going to be free market oriented and it
turns out that now the corporate world
is
indoctrinating its own employees in the
same sort of critical race theory
that the universities were
indoctrinating their students with in
the late 1980s early 1990s
yeah because people respond to
demonization and pressure
they they head for the tall grass
ceos of corporations don't want to lose
customers they're not brave people
it's an extortion racket when i came
into the
right 40 years ago the first thing i
said what
looked around and said was where's the
ground army
my ex-comrades on the left have
hundreds if not thousands of
organizations
whose business is threatening
politicians
and corporations intimidating them
you know jackson and sharpton made
careers out of racial extortion
you go to a beer company and say give us
10 million dollars
or we're going to call you racist and
boycott you
uh and that was told to me by a witness
of that happening bob beckel
uh not that he will say it publicly
where are the where the conservative
organization's grassroots
well donald trump has given the
conservative movement and the country
a great gift because he has created the
first
mass conservative movement in our
history
it it's clearly numbered in the millions
but just if you just think of the
hundreds of thousands of people who
turned out for his campaign rallies
that's that that's the basic
army that can uh save our country
they get conservatives need to get in
the face
of these teachers look what the teacher
unions have done
they they've damaged the lives of
millions
of k-12 kids because they don't they
don't want to teach they just want to
collect their paychecks
you've got to go in the face of the
teachers of the principals
of the school boards why isn't there a
sit-in
at twitter headquarters or facebook
making their lives
miserable and exposing to them
then press will flock to it and you can
tell the whole country what
sensors they are and what fascists they
are basically
and what hypocrites as we know they let
iranian mullahs preach the death of
america on their
sites while banning the president of the
united states
i mean what greater act of censorship
is there than to de-platform the
president of the united states which
they've done
so what conservatives have to do is they
have to start being
more aggressive calling things by their
right names
use words like fascist when it's
fascistic
it's fascist it's racist
to demonize your opponents with no
evidence whatsoever
to call republica what happened on
january 6 an
armed insurrection is the way fascists
deploy politics
not you know americans
not small d democrats
they don't do that they're polite that's
what the collegiality is about
used to be in the congress
bipartisanship
how could you be bipartisan with a with
a party that you're
calling enemies of the state you can't
but no you know and it's true that the
media is
a bunch of liars they all what happened
to the media is that in the old days
uh reporters actually never went to
college
uh they went out on the streets and they
reported what they saw
but these journalism schools have been
corrupt for
30 years you know i i had lunch with the
chairman of the
journalism department as a decent left
up center uh a leftist center person
um and i asked him i said michael d
do you have any conservatives on your
journalism faculty
he said i can't think of one i said do
you think that's a good idea for
training journalists or for
education in the first place not to
to have purged all conservatives he said
no i don't
i said what can you do about it he said
nothing because the professors
hire themselves and that's been going on
for 30 years i can tell you the columbia
school of journalism is the same way
nyu it's the same way all these elite
institutions are one-party states
the unit you know this better than
anyone been what one party states the
universities are
if a conservative appears on campus it
gets boycotted by professors
and the left comes into his event and
turns it into a circus
and the administrators think it's funny
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel so you don't miss out on
any of our content